bah voilà qu'elle est lié la traversée
de l'atlantique en solitaire à 2
mesdames messieurs le dvd quel exploit
mais oui ça fait bizarre d'avoir ça
parce qu'on a vraiment vécu des moments
très durs on l'a un peu déçu que les
gens rigolent là dessus parce que pour
nous c'est pas franchement quand est-ce
qu'on vous êtes vraiment seul au milieu
d'un studio du de l'atlantique
vous l'aurez bassin non j'aime alain
après on va tenter la traversée du
désert comme tous les artistes
ah oui alors tous les deux mon dieu vous
avez un rêve depuis votre première
rencontre
oui un rêve précis un rêve tu en as un
rêve lancinant ce rêve bleu veilleux un
rêve taroudant qui revient toujours
depuis 12 ans ce rêve c'est un film
qu'olivier réalisera le cade legrand cad
à base de sucre interpréterez tout à
fait oui hein c'est quoi ce film c'était
un fils manqué qui est en face
d'écriture qui se termine la journée
mois de juin et voilà on en a réalisé ce
rêve c'est à dire qu'il ya les
producteurs qui nous ont fait confiance
et voilà on va ça va ça va se faire on
voit déjà on va d'abord tourné à un
premier film avec la même équipe que
pamela rose
oui un ticket pour l'espace et au mois
de juin après on va enchaîner avec ce
film qui va s'appeler simplement une vie
de rêve et kde aura le rôle principal
moi je les écris je vais le réaliser
le pitch il est génial oui le pitch et
katia grands le pitch est quelqu'un qui
reçoit un pouvoir un jour et ce pouvoir
c'est de réaliser ses rêves c'est dans
la soirée s'endort il reste par exemple
comme kde c'est un grand acteur
nos matins il travaille c'est un gros
tracteur et ainsi de suite
ouais donc c'est génial au début mais il
a oublié une chose c'est clair elle ça
peut aussi devenir des cauchemars oh mon
dieu et voilà quoi et là ça va mal se
passer pour lui
et à la fin on comprend tout pourquoi ce
qui lui arrive tout ça pourquoi est ce
qu'il a ce pouvoir extraordinaire et un
mois c'est vous tous les deux les yeux
les uns
alors désormais que c'est très connu
tous les deux très très connu dans le
14e arrondissement activement vous avez
déclaré dans la rue on nous remarque
aussi facilement que thierry ardisson
c'est vrai ce sérum et dont on nous
parle souvent de toi contre non je dis
vous dire toujours chez drucker
d'abord on n'a pas réfléchi drucker en
plus on était chauds touché thierry
ouais donc c'est difficile pour vous de
faire des trucs comme avant sur
n'importe quoi puisque maintenant tout
le monde vous connaît assez sûr d'aller
chez le médecin soigne et me cause par
exemple c'est tout de suite là ou quoi
et le bar on va on y aille alors